life in Catania in northern Italy is now
happening behind closed doors the town's
mayor has told the 15,000 residents to
stay at home to prevent the spread of
the coronavirus Rosica Valley is one of
the few people venturing out
she owns a pharmacy and the mayor has
told her to keep it open
Davi more poll would our point of
chamalla Manny we're all afraid but
we're crossing our fingers we'll be all
right
if someone doesn't feel well they should
react early because people can be cured
if they come to hospital in a desperate
situation it's much more difficult to
cure them two people have died of
coronavirus in northern Italy and with
dozens infected it's Europe's worst hit
country as many experts are saying we
will probably see many more cases of
infection over the next days as people
now are more afraid of the virus and
will likely ask more for a check by
medical stuff whereas up to two or three
days ago the virus was perceived as
something very far from Italy
Prime Minister Giuseppe Conte has
announced a ban on people entering or
leaving zones designated coronavirus
hotspots but he's ruled out suspending
the European Union Schengen Agreement
and says the free movement of people and
goods across Italy's borders will
continue m'lady
at the moment there are absolutely no
conditions for an initiative of this
kind not to mention the devastating
impact it would have on our economy and
paradoxically I want to reverse the
question why would we want to make Italy
an outcast there are no conditions for
it to come to this nor do we want to do
it Catania is one of a dozen towns in
northern Italy that's in lockdown
Italians say they're frightened and have
no idea when life will return to normal
Victoria gate MB Al Jazeera